good afternoon everyone uh thank you so
much for joining us today I am super
excited for a conversation we're about
to have with Simon cnnic my name if you
haven't met is Alan Richardson and I
have the pleasure of leading the talent
strategy and services Solutions team
here at RBC uh and we're very pleased to
Welcome All of You our participants and
alumni of our women in leadership and
ignite programs You're such important
Talent leaders of our firm and we're
really excited to have this conversation
with Simon and learn so much from one of
The Visionaries of leadership uh today
uh Simon welcome you probably don't need
too much of an intro but for those that
may not have Googled you uh Simon is an
author of multiple bestselling books uh
starting with the first which is start
with why and a famous Ted Talk that
really kicked off uh a a revolution in
leadership that is built on Simon's
unshakable optimism in the future uh
through a number of books uh one that my
team read called the infinite game and
if you have the pleasure of uh picking
up one of those books that's the one I
would suggest personally I thought it
was a great view of how leaders and and
business need to change for the future
um it's such a pleasure to have you
Simon thank you so much for joining uh
and
welcome thanks for having me nice to be
here uh so Simon I I think we'll start
where where you started and and talk
about finding your why uh and you know
leaders today it's it's a it's a it's a
crazy world it's a vuka world it's a
world that is uncertain and and hard to
deal with and challenging and leaders I
think struggle more than ever to
identify why why am I here why am I
leading uh why is our organization doing
what we do and if you could take us
through your journey and sort of how you
see that playing out today for leaders
in the world I I think that would be a
great place to start
so absolutely I I'll share I think one
uh one perspective that I think is very
very helpful um when we when Co showed
up and we all went into lockdown um I
was paying attention to how leaders were
reacting and what I saw is quite
fascinating which is the number of
leaders who in these extremely difficult
times lean back into their own
Humanity um in other words they picked
up the telephone they called their team
members one by one and they said how are
you and where there are effective or
ineffective leaders prior to co this is
how most people reacted and by the way
that's just called good leadership and
it doesn't require stress or a pandemic
to be concerned with somebody else's
well-being and I I said this all through
the pandemic which is I hope this lasts
um uh because like I said it doesn't
matter it's good times or hard times
that is being concerned with how how
someone leads and I think that's sort of
the big change that's been happening in
leadership for the past sort of 20 or 30
years which is became so obsessed with
short-termism we became so obsessed with
annual numbers and quarterly numbers and
we started to excessively use the lies
of human beings to manage quarterly and
annual results um the use of mass
layoffs for example uh to meet uh uh
arbitrary targets at the end of the year
didn't exist uh prior to the 1980s it
just didn't exist in in in the way it
does and now I think we're starting to
see the results we're starting to see
push back we're starting to be CN about
capitalism we're starting to see
reduction in loyalty and for good reason
um and so now I think the the the
pendulum is swinging the other way and I
think the the the good news is is that
good leadership is the is the solution
to so many of the challenges we're
facing in business
today that's fantastic and so as leaders
are searching for that and and from the
basis of you know a human Centric style
of leadership uh and thinking about um
trust as that currency that you need to
build
what are you seeing great leaders do uh
you know the reach out I think is an
important First Step but what are they
doing to build that trust and to to sort
of expand the relationship they have
with their
employees so there's a an irony to all
of this which is which is a lot of us
already know how to do this stuff like
have you ever been on a date have you
ever made a friend right like we know
how to build trust you know our survival
depends on these social skills and for
some reason uh when we get to work those
skills seem to go out the window um and
so there's massive opportunity for uh
companies to start teaching human skills
um I hate the term soft skills you know
hard skills are the skills we need to do
our job and human skills the skills we
need to be better humans and what you
need is a balance of both of those
skills you know hard and soft are
opposite we don't want skills that work
against each other and so human skills
include things like how to have a a
difficult conversation how to have an
effective confrontation how to give and
receive feedback how to listen actively
how to demonstrate empathy um and
believe it or not these skills are
difficult you know and we have to learn
them and when when somebody joins our
company we give them tons of training
how to do their job whatever their job
is we train them some people get
Advanced degrees in how to do their jobs
why so they'll be good at their job but
then we put people in leadership
positions and give them little to no
training on how to lead we don't teach
them human skills and Leadership is a
human job you're no longer doing the job
you're now leading other people who do
the job you used to do um there's a big
difference between a salesperson and a
sales manager for example they're
completely different skill sets so I
think there's a massive opportunity to
start teaching human skills and that's
that's what makes the difference it
feels like sometimes we kind of expect
people to to your point to bring that
with them and and don't necessarily
focus on that in our training efforts I
think the other result I see is you see
too many player coaches so it's leaders
who are still doing and not actually
focusing their attention and efforts on
on leadership absolutely and and so as
you you know RBC really is focused very
much on our clients and putting our
clients first on our communities and
supporting our communities as in
financial institutions play such an
important role there which we believe
brings purpose to what we do um but I
think then it's finding and and what are
you seeing in terms of how people are
connecting their teams to that purpose
in challenging times when there's so
many different pressures to your point
we still have quarterly goals and
measures as do any large organization
but how how are they then connecting
that to and and from my standpoint I'm
thinking about the why uh as opposed to
the how which I see a lot of leaders
focusing how first and why third maybe
uh talk a little bit about why you put
the why
first I mean you said it you said it
right there and then which is which is
the hierarchy matters you I've never met
a CEO who doesn't think their people are
important the problem is we're in the
hierarchy you know I've been to so many
corporate presentations and I watched
CEOs present you know our priorities and
number one is growth number two is
shareholder value number three is our
customer number four is our employees
they way are we care about people
they're right there number four on the
list um uh uh and the problem is is is
that's a hierarchy which means are you
willing to sacrifice your people in
order to hit a number uh that's what
that's what that list says and that's
what that list communicates to the
people who work inside an organization
and so the organizations that tend to
outperform their competitors over time
what you'll see is that people come
first and that we would rather sacrifice
short-term gains to protect our people
than sacrifice our people to protect
short-term gains because to have a round
of mass layoffs to protect a short-term
number produces such long-term ripples
of damage to trust that You' spent so
long building um that it it takes it
takes an extremely long time to rebuild
that trust um much longer than it would
take to to to rebuild the numbers um uh
and so I I I always pay attention to
that hierarchy you're 100% right the
order matters in terms of starting with
why the order matters for a slightly
different reason which is the reason of
biology which is this is what I learned
when I talked about why how and what
it's not my opinion that level those
levels overlap with the biology of human
decision making so when you start with
how or what you're actually engaging the
uh the neocortex which is the rational
language center of our brains but not
responsible for feelings or behavior
when you start with why you're engaging
the lyic brain which is uh responsible
for feelings and behavior so that lyic
brain is responsible for getting stuff
done so when people feel connected to
the organization when they feel
connected to the mission they more
likely going to make decisions that will
advance that mission and the
organization
itself and I think that ALS speak to you
know leadership comes in a few different
forms you you can lead through your
hierarchy I'm your boss you know you got
to do this you can lead through rational
logic hey you I have a good argument you
can do it or you can lead through that
emotional connection and I think what
you're saying is you got to get to that
emotional connection first and then the
rational and the the hierarchy can come
afterwards but make sure there's that
that trust uh connection I think that's
that's so important you know and so you
know well
put so as you as you look towards the
future now we're hitting tough Economic
Times and to your point leaders are
going to have to make choices and
prioritization decisions um and as you
as you clearly put employees first in
your hierarchy it feels like how do you
encourage leaders to Think Through what
do I do to make my employees both
successful and perform and hold them
accountable for performance but on the
same time have that human Centric
empathetic feel I think sometimes people
feel it's either either one or the other
it's not both yeah no of course they can
coexist but it you know it's it's it's
the art of leadership it's there is
science of leadership but this is the
art of leadership which is it's not
always clear um you know if you go too
far in the direction of performance
performance performance you build an
organization filled with mercenaries
that will stab each other in the back to
hit numbers and hit personal uh uh uh uh
rewards um if you slide the uh two far
the other direction you know you have a
hippie commune where everybody loves
each other but no work gets done and
there's no accountability and and this
is the hard part about leadership which
is it's it's it's it's like marriage
it's like friendship it's like children
which is you'll never be on the path
you're constantly blocking and tackling
and trying to make it work but what
makes it work over the course of time is
that strong Foundation of trust that
when you screw up or get it wrong or
you're grumpy or you're tired that
people are patient with you um and it's
just viewing people as human beings and
bringing empathy to work now usually
when I talk about these themes um you
know people find them uncomfortable now
I know this is women in leadership that
we're talking to and I will say that
women understand my work better than men
you know I talk about the stuff and
women tend to go yeah and men tend to
say do you have any case studies you
know and uh uh so when I talk about
bringing empathy to work there's nothing
there's nothing mushy or weak about this
I I'll give you a simple example um uh
here's a fairly normal scenario you know
a manager walks into one of their
reports office and says hey I've noticed
your numbers are down for the third
quarter in a row we've had this
conversation before if you don't pick up
your numbers in the fourth quarter I
don't know what's going to happen right
that's a fairly common scenario here is
that same scenario with empathy injected
hey um I noticed your numbers are down
for the third quarter in a row we've had
this conversation before are you okay
I'm worried about you what's going on
that's empathy injected into into
leadership where you actually concerned
about the person rather than the than
than missing the number and what you'll
find is people will open up ask for help
tell you what the challenges are maybe
they have struggles at home maybe
they've been put in a position where
they don't actually have the training to
do the job there's a wealth of things
that we can support and help and by the
way when we do that not only does it
build trust but um it actually helps the
performance because we can help we know
what the what the root of the what the
problem is and so we need more of that
at work in order to produce High
performing teams you know when I talk
about high performing teams and I've
looked at some of the most highest
performing teams you know in the world
what you'll find is deep deep deep
levels of trust love and
camaraderie that's fantastic start there
and then work on the rest but we have to
have that base first before we begin I I
I'm I'm I this is making me think you
know sort of performance shortterm
versus long term and uh I'm going to
butcher it so maybe I'll ask you to
Define when you talk about a finite game
versus an infinite game you are talking
a bit about that short versus long term
Maybe you can explain for us the concept
of the infinite game in sort of the
business concept and and an example of
how we could think about that in our
world and how we could approach banking
which is an infinite game uh from that
standpoint absolutely so in the mid
1980s a philosopher and theologian by
the name of Dr James cars defined these
two types of games finite games and
infinite games a finite game is defined
as known players fixed rules and an
agreed upon objective football baseball
um if there's a winner necessarily there
have to be losers and there's always a
beginning a middle and an end that's
very important um a new business pitch
for example right there's going to be a
beginning a middle and end there's going
to be a winner and a loser that's a
finite game um then you have infinite
games infinite games are defined as
known and unknown players which means
you don't necessarily know who all the
players are and new players can join the
game whenever they want the rules are
changeable which means every player
player can play however they want and
the objective is to perpetuate the game
to stay in the game as long as possible
so we are players in infinite games
every day of Our Lives whether we know
it or not there's no such thing as
winning global politics no one will ever
win career or education or health um and
definitely there's no such thing as
winning business nobody's declared the
winner of business ever you know when
when Circuit City went bankrupt Best Buy
didn't win anything uh but if we listen
to the language of too many of our
leaders it becomes abundantly clear that
they don't actually know the game
they're playing in they talk obsessively
about being number one or being the best
or beating their competition based on
what based upon what agreed upon metrics
uh time frame or objectives and this is
a problem because when we play with a
finite mindset in an infinite game and
we play to win in a game that has no
Finish Line there are some very
predictable and consistent outcomes the
big ones are the decline of trust the
decline of cooperation
and the decline of innovation and so the
more shortterm we think and the more we
think about business as a game will we
treat the financial year as the end of
the game which it's not um the more
damage we do to the long-term prospects
of the
organization that's fantastic and
certainly from the standpoint of banking
we're always making investments in loans
that have a long-term nature to them so
it's not like I can sell a product and
walk away from it I'm stuck with that on
my books for years uh in the case of
mortgages decades right so that that's
absolutely important um you know as we
as we think about that competitiveness
and we look to drive performance you
know in and we're especially uh based in
Canada and and in the United States but
we we do play in in the global sphere
what do what do you think we need to be
mindful of as we sort of trend through
the next few years and I I think we've
touched on a few of those topics but as
you're looking at leaderships and you're
thinking of GR great teams and what
they're doing right now to prepare for
five or 10 years out what are they
talking about what are they thinking
about well I'm going to sound like a
broken record which is the great
competitive the great competitive
advantage that a lot of companies are
missing is the quality of the culture
and the quality of your long-term
strategy right when when companies
articulate um finite goals and as their
longterm strategy to be number one or
hit certain goals in five years you know
that's a finite goal that's not what
that is and by the way just to go off on
a slight tangent you know finite
infinite games are not mutually
exclusive you can have finite games
within the infinite game right but the
infinite game is the context within
which those finite games exist so to
have a long-term Vision that is not
about some uh uh goal when we confuse
goals with long-term Vision long-term
vision is how we imagine the world and
how we're going to use our companies to
contribute to the building of that world
in other words you say you're customer
focused then you kind have your
long-term Vision be about you because
then you're not customer focused focused
if you're customer focused and you have
a long-term vision of the kinds of lives
you want your customers and clients to
live of how you want the community and
Society to look like and you will use
your business to advance towards that
vision and the goals you set are the
markers that demonstrate metrics proof
that you're moving closer and closer
towards that think of it like running a
marathon like you can't run a marathon
without mile markers like the metrics
are good but they are an indication of
progress of speed and distance towards
something even bigger and grander it
strikes me that that's probably why a
lot of us and a lot of companies a lot
of politicians and and organizations
generally are struggling with the
climate story because there's not an end
to the climate story it's not like we're
going to solve climate by 202030 it will
be a forever fight that we need to be
constantly involved in and and I guess
creating that mindset in how we're
approaching it and telling our story
that way uh becomes much more powerful
what do you see you know
you talk about unshakable optimism if
there's a time to be shaken though it
feels like now is that time how are you
feeling generally and I'll step outside
of RBC in banking but how are you
feeling generally about the track that
the world is on and are you still
calling yourself an unshakable optimist
as you look at the world around you
today the simple answer is yes I am
still an unshakable optimist I think
people confuse optimism and blind
positivity you know optimism is not
naive
it is very realistic you know blind
positivity positivity you know a lot of
leaders think that they have to be
positive for their teams to be positive
no matter how bad things get
everything's fine everything's fine
everything's good and that actually
backfires because when we're struggling
when we're in periods of high stress and
we see our boss apparently think
everything's fine it actually can make
us feel worse there must be something
wrong with me if I'm so doomsday and
they're so light um uh that's not
helpful optimism is nothing like that
optimism is the UN dying belief that the
future is bright and it allows for dark
reality so for example I can say to my
team Hey listen this is a dark tunnel
that we're in um I don't know how long
we're going to be in this tunnel um it's
going to suck for a while um but there's
one thing I know is that there's a light
at the end of this tunnel and if we work
together we will get through this and
come out of this stronger than we went
in that's what optimism sounds like
that's great and and it makes me think
of Alan malali who would always say the
the moment that I stop hearing things
from my employees to the newspaper but
they come to me I know I'm having the
right dialogue with them about where
we're actually at and yes he's a very
optimistic guy like you are but he but
he fundamentally felt that they had to
be having very real conversations
speaking of real conversations so both
of these programs I mentioned are for uh
colleagues from uh diverse backgrounds
um and and folks that we really believe
uh you know face challenges above the
average in the workplace today um and
there's 's a lot you know uh I think
going on in the world today uh again
caused for optimism caused for reality
checks of where we're at and where we're
headed um you know from your standpoint
of as you see uh leaders of all walks
from all different sort of uh frames and
backgrounds and and uh perspectives be
successful what are the things that you
find most common you know no matter
where you come from that anybody can can
lean into as as as sort of a a building
their success in their career career
over over the the time they're they're
growing their leadership
career for individuals for individuals
yeah thinking of the group so yeah yeah
so so so leadership is a journey um
there's no such thing as perfect leader
there's also no such thing as an expert
in leadership I am not an expert in
leadership I'm a student of leadership
um I may be a more advanced student than
some but I'm a student nonetheless and
there's always more to learn just like
there's no such thing as the perfect
parent right it doesn't exist um and
every day we think we've screwed up our
kids um forever right it's a constant
journey of
convers uh
oh sorry everyone I think we just lost
Simon oh Simon sir we lost you for about
10 seconds there I think you're back can
you uh just start okay yeah yeah
absolutely so uh they say to her is
human but to really screw things up
requires a computer so
um live television right um absolutely
so uh leadership is a journey and
there's no such thing as an expert
leader um just like there's no such
thing as an expert parent um and I think
of myself as a student of leadership not
an expert don't trust anybody who says
they're an expert in the subject because
they're not um and if you're going to go
on this journey you have to have a
students mindset um so you have to be
always curious that there's more to
learn um you have to read books you have
to have talks you have to talk to other
friends just like as parents we talk to
other parents we talk to our parents we
read books we read articles constantly
constantly constantly and so some of the
great leaders I've met they're wonderful
they're incredible they could tell me
that they're an expert in leadership
because all I want to do is learn from
them all they want to do when we go out
for dinner is talk about leadership like
they have insatiable curiosity for the
subject that they love and so this is
this is how this is how it works which
is if we we have to be on on a
leadership journey and I'll add one more
thing which is leadership is really
really really difficult and I would
never advise anybody going on a
leadership journey by themselves just
like you would never do anything
difficult by yourself you go scuba
diving you go to war you always have a a
buddy well make sure you have a
leadership buddy to go on your journey
with where you can constantly compare
notes that's great and and someone to to
check you and certainly we we also uh
love coaches and having a coach who can
sort of mentor you I think it's
something that we are slowly observing
from the sports world is how do you
actually create coaching more ingrained
in the in the journey that leaders need
to take uh is absolutely critical um you
know you mentioned parents and I'm I'm
going to go back to uh your runaway
Millennial video for a second uh if I
may and you know you pointed out then
the dangers of social media this was
2017 you pointed out the dangers of a of
a culture where everyone is actually
looking on their their phone we then
went into the pandemic and multitasking
became simple it was actually kind of
easy though I'm told I'm not necessarily
the best at hiding when I'm multitasking
but some you know we we I see a pretty
significant shift to multitasking as
we've come back from uh sort of a remote
world and I'm interested to to sort of
as you think about it six years later
are you more panicked or more worried
about the impact of uh sort of a
multitasking world or do you think it's
something that we are getting a handle
on or is it less of a concern
today there is no data to show that
human beings are capable of
multitasking uh it is it is you can do
one thing well two things mediocre and
three things are more badly um and if
you've ever been having a conversation
with somebody and they pick up their
phone and look down and you think that
they're listening to you it's never
happened in the history of human
humankind so there is no such thing as
multitasking right um we can stack
things and I think one of the things
that we've done is we've and and and I
have this conversation with young people
just because they're Adept at their
phones and they're Adept at social media
they have the false belief that they can
multitask talk to any Bost and talk to
any college Professor about the quality
of writing and the quality of work and
you'll see that it's declined because
it's write a little bit check my phone
write a little bit check my phone and
you'll see that they might write great
sentences or great paragraphs except
those paragraphs are not connected to
each other um so there's no such thing
as multitasking so let's just forget
that um what the pandemic has done um uh
you to your point um other people are
just better at faking it than you are um
and what the P pandemic has done
unfortunately has made us very
comfortable working from home and um um
and for especially young people but for
a lot of us um we think that we've won
the lottery that this is the world's
greatest way to work where I can have
total freedom um uh and and make a
living and be a part of a team but for
the fact that we're not members of teams
um you know Isaac Stern said um the
famous violinist said trust he said
music happens between the notes well
trust happens between the meetings right
it's the walking into the meeting and
the chitchat and it's the walking out of
the meeting where we're Contin the
chitchat it's the bumping into somebody
in the hallway and being like Oh I meant
to tell you it's grabbing somebody and
saying hey you want to get a cup of
coffee and it's all these seemingly
innocuous little interactions that by
themselves Mount you know do nothing but
in uh uh uh in in in concert they
actually build human relationship and
the problem with online is all of those
inet are gone all we have is the meeting
that's it that's all we've got and so
it's extremely difficult to build Trust
online you actually to do more work it's
it's you know like any company that that
that's just doing it the same and just
having the meetings no you have to
really do more work and artificially
create social interaction and even then
and I've had a virtual company for over
10 years even then we still have
business trips where we visit each other
and we still have offsites where we come
together as an entire team because we
know that nothing replaces nothing
replaces good oldfashioned uh human
interaction and by the way you cannot do
brainstorming or have great creativity
online it just doesn't exist um you can
do it you can do it in person very
easily because we interrupt each other
and it's you know whereas online is very
very formal like everybody's on mute
nobody wants to speak you know um uh
it's not interruptive and and and
chaotic um which is what you need for
brainstorming so so we can live in a
hybrid world where both exist but but I
think for too many they believe the
future of work is is is online and it'll
be to the detriment of the company but
worse it'll be to the det M of the
mental health of the person who never
interacts with people
right that that's well said and and
certainly something that I think are our
our CEO Dave mcki would agree with you
firmly on and we are certainly on that
Journey sort of learning to work in a
hybrid World which as you said is not as
easy as working in a purely in-person
world where those collisions happen
naturally it's much more structured uh
and you have to be very thoughtful about
how you manage it um as you think of
sorry yeah I was going to add one more
thought but yes please really quickly
I'm fully aware and I recognize that the
old working world where everybody came
to work all the time favored the
extroverts I get that and the introverts
sometimes struggled but when we went to
a fully remote World which the
introverts loved now the extroverts were
struggling because they need that human
interaction right and so there's always
going to be a loser in in in these
scenarios if we choose one or and if we
truly love our teams the correct answer
answer is I will sacrifice some of the
time so that the people I work with can
Thrive the way that they Thrive so as an
introvert I accept that I sometimes have
to come to work and as an extrovert I
accept that sometimes I have to be uh
separated because it helps my colleagues
and the point is is we're making it an
act of service we're making flexible
work and figuring out how work Works uh
for each other where I think too much of
the conversation has been about me and
how I like to work and that's you're not
the only person on the team and so there
is no perfect work scenario I get that
and the question is I'm willing to
sacrifice some so That Others May Thrive
I think that's that's great and it's
that sense of how do we the the the
importance of Team especially in today's
world we don't all have the answers we
don't all have no one person is the
heroic leader who's got everything today
not that that was ever true um but as a
result understanding how you bring the
best out of your team and if anything
that management of your team has gotten
harder because you're you're actually
adding dimension iions that we didn't
have to think about before um that's
that's that's absolutely right so so
then as you think about um a leader with
all these pressures and they are trying
to get the performance out of their team
be balanced with empathy um this and
we've heard this this is leading to
burnout at a pretty big scale um and and
you know you see it uh in different ways
I think often senior leaders show
burnout very differently because they're
such a hard driving person they're just
not willing to give up but are you
seeing this as a a potential sort of as
a risk that we are dealing with as
organizations and and what are you
seeing on the you know how do you
address burnout and how are you uh how
do you suggest we go about sort of
thinking about that from a leadership
standpoint so the simple answer is yes
um and and and what I think is so funny
is the language I mean we've heard the
language of quiet quitting well quiet
quitting is is what uh people in
positions of leadership say that people
who are more Junior are doing but when
we talk about our qu quitting we talk
about finding work life balance right
so everybody's a quiet quitter and
everybody's looking for work life
balance it all depends on which
perspective you're looking from um so
there's a few things that help reduce uh
burnout and and that one is the Fe the
biggest one is the is is the trust that
someone has my back right and and this
is I think one of the things we didn't
expect when we had remote work which is
that that burnout was going to happen a
lot higher um because I'm working all
the time now and the barriers are
breaking down as to when when I stop
working when I'm not working we don't
have that work life separation that that
the separation of church and state as
clearly anymore like the boundaries are
very difficult and then when we talk
about people establishing boundaries you
know sometimes they can come across as
aggressive like that's crossing my
boundary and missing the fact that we're
a team here and these boundaries are
difficult and fuzzy um uh uh and so one
of the biggest helpers of of to reduce
burnout is one um relationships
relationships relationships make sure
you have somebody who you can go to and
say I'm struggling I'm having a hard day
um I'm fed up I'm mad I hate this screw
this job venting venting is healthy um
and we don't really get to vent much
when we're in a fully online way because
we we you know we we and especially
during the pandemic we saw this which is
we used to go to work then go and meet
our friends for drinks or dinner after
work and vent very healthy right then
what happened when we went into the
pandemic which is we go to work and then
that's it nothing nothing no way to get
the stress out so that's number one
please relationships relationships
relationships the other one is is is
learning how to uh prioritize uh me time
um and it's more simple than you think
like we often put things in our
calendars that though we put them in our
calendar they're not fixed for example
you want to go work out right and you
put in your in your in your calendar
from 3 to 4 p.m. I'm going to out and
then somebody says hey can you meet at 3
4 p.m. and the first thing you do is cut
it out right um so what I do is I
actually put an hour a week you know
I'll put an and it's called it's called
creative time or me time and I treat it
like it's a meeting right so when
somebody says to me can you meet at you
know two to three on Thursday and I look
at my calendar and it says creative time
I say sorry I have a conflict can I meet
you on on Friday in the morning now of
course there are always sometimes
emergencies that th those those spaces
get filled but I've become very
protective of these little recharge
moments where I will not put any
meetings in there and I can choose to do
with those creative spaces what I want I
can do creative work or sometimes I can
catch up on things that I'm struggling
to catch up on the point is I get to
dictate what happens in that time and uh
the most important thing is to be super
protective of them you don't need a lot
of them but you do need them yeah and
and that speaks to a broader point and
it goes back to the earlier discussion
time man management seems to be a bit of
a lost skill um we've packed our days
full and we're not leaving Flex for uh
how do we spend our time on those longer
term things how do we spend our times on
Creative or on ourselves and it's just
booked to and that was also I think
something that happened in the pandemic
as you said where we just crammed our
day full of meetings because that's all
we really had had time for and how are
you thinking you know what would be your
suggestions more
broadly around the time management if
there's anything else there but and and
just in terms of how critical that is
because I'm seeing that as a as an
element of what what's driving some of
the sort of swirl and ambiguity is truly
at its root time
management yeah so again I'm a slave to
my calendar as well so instead of trying
to escape my calendar I built in the the
the gaps in the calendar so I'm still a
slave to the calendar I look forward to
these little gaps that are that are
there and very very protective so that's
that's number one yeah
um I think the other thing uh uh when it
comes to time management is is defining
work days you know the workday has
become fuzzy um because we used to have
a commute and the the commute in you
would sort of prepare for work listen to
the news whatever it was have your
coffee and then the commute out the
commute home is sort of recharge and
sort of like ah just sort of whether you
had a drive or you're on a train or
whatever it was you got you got a moment
to yourself to sort of to relax until
you got home and and now we go
immediately from one thing to the next
so actually really like the idea of
defining the workday now of course it's
going to be imperfect just like real
work sometimes you work late sometimes
you have to come in early totally
totally fine but for ourselves to define
the workday that it that it's not a
morphous I think is an important thing
um good thing about work and problems is
they'll still be there tomorrow once you
close your computer that's right I I was
actually dreading my commute when I
started to come back to the office I
ended up loving it because it was
exactly that I was like I get to read
listen to music no one's bugging me
there's no kids like it was great no I
think the commute the commute is the
great uncelebrated uh uh buffer between
work and home yeah that's fantastic um
we we've gone through a lot of topics
very quickly we are so far off our
script that it's wonderful uh and we
still have a few more minutes but I'd
love to to to turn the conversation to
you Simon and and sort of what do you
you know if if if you have a few minutes
what are you thinking about right now
like what are you exploring in your
research you you call yourself an
eternal student of leadership what are
you learning about right now what is on
your
mind uh there's a few things uh frankly
um one of them is this concept of power
you know the simple utterance of the
word um makes some people sort of glow
with desire and other people afraid of
it and some people thinking it evil and
some people thinking it good um and if
you look at so many of the challenges we
are facing politically internationally
um even inside our our our own companies
it seems to be a lot of power struggle
um it also raises the question of
external power versus internal power
power that comes from numbers versus
feeling powerless yourself or feeling
that you're subjected or have somebody
else has power over you and and and how
we have unhealthy reactions to those
feelings and so it become very very
interesting what it means to manage
power and Balance power in a modern day
and age given all the factors that we've
talked about some of already um so I've
become very very interested in in in
that that's fascinating and I think
power is you you sort of mentioned
the it's the control right and that was
something that we saw in the pandemic
was the loss of control was a lot of
what drove people's anxiety because they
could not they didn't feel they were in
control anymore um and again as you
think about where we are and the world
we're in that sense of control is often
something that we miss and and makes us
feel powerless um and so are you are you
looking at that in terms of how people
and leaders specifically build control
you know over themselves uh through
their organizations is that something
that would be part of that yeah
absolutely like if you have power if you
have positions of power how do you
manage that responsibly um I I'll give
you one little sta statistic that I
stumbled upon um which will make perfect
sense when I say it but especially as a
bank you realize the power you have to
help people feel powerful rather than
power lless which is um uh this little
statistic that that a disproportionately
high number of the January 6 Invaders
the in in the capital in Washington DC a
disproportionately high number of them
either were struggling with or have
struggled with significant financial
stress including personal bankruptcy or
significant credit card debt way way
higher than the national average yeah so
if you think about that um you know
somebody who feels power less because
they're drowning in debt or uh unable to
take control of their financial future
what does that do to somebody's mindset
um when when they feel that way and I
think I think that's an amazing an
amazing opportunity that that a that a
bank can recognize that somebody who's
struggling feels powerless and how do we
help them feel powerful simply by
getting them on a track where they can
see that there's a light at the end of
the tunnel yeah I I spent nearly a
decade as a consultant and externally
looking at a bank you see the the loans
and the deposits and it seems very
transactional um but coming into the
bank you realize to your point the
influence you have over a society and
Community by being the lifeblood by by
generating capital and deploying capital
and I think it is a great responsibility
that that we do feel absolutely but then
to your point uh seeing that for its
very specific consequences like you
suggest on on the January 6th I think is
always important for us to have um part
of our part of our sort of in our in our
thinking um but as you go go with that
it is um how do we as a bank take uh
where is the right points for us to take
a stand on that and how do we affect
change through that uh is really
important important for us to consider
um that's
fantastic sorry and it goes to what
you're before about being customer
focused right doesn't mean you have to
be a charity but how we talk to people
you know just the simple way how we how
we treat people you know I've written
about um this woman named Christina
Harbridge who had a collections agency
um and she outperformed by by
multiples uh other collections agencies
in in uh uh in her C well I guess all
they're all in the same C but
outperformed other collections agencies
not because of her her mean tactics but
because she treated people with respect
instead of calling people up and
threatening them that they owe money she
called them up and said hey I know
you're struggling can we work this out
together like there are certain things
that we I have to do but like let me
work with you and the minute somebody
just felt like they were being treated
like a human being and somebody on the
other side of the phone understood they
don't want to be in debt they don't want
to not pay their bills they're they're
struggling and just that somebody
understood that they were struggling
they were able to get way more people
into payment plans that worked even
though they were the exact same payment
plans that a threatening methodology was
attempting to deploy um and like I said
she she outperformed um and people said
Thank you at the ends of the calls so
it's not necessarily what we have to do
but it's how we go about doing it and
having that customer focus that can have
profound impact on someone's life yeah
that's fantastic the money that we need
to collect yeah yeah you can still be
profitable and drive performance but do
it in a way right absolutely which seems
absolutely the theme of this call that's
fantastic uh I I think we probably have
uh just one one or two more questions
here Simon so thank you so much for your
time um you know I as we think about uh
the trends and that are happening uh and
and you sort of spoke to this in terms
of the January 6 group um but certainly
labor unions are far more active uh
we've seen the strikes with the Auto
Workers you know as you as you look
forward in in the economy and as the
economy sort of St stutters as we go
forward um you know leaders I think are
going to have to make hard choices and
you've spoken before about the long and
the short term um what is your
encouragement what would you say to RBC
in terms of your encouragement for how
we need to hold ourselves to thinking
about that long term and how how what
are the things you would ask us to think
through as we go go forward through the
next couple years I this is the value of
the infinite game it's this is summarize
this is the purpose of the infinite game
which is which is you don't have
competitors in your industry that you
need to beat right it's a f it's a false
uh narrative this is the magical thing
about business it's an infinite game and
multiple companies selling about the
same product about the same price about
the same quality can both be wildly
successful at the same time um and to
view the other players in your category
to view the other players in your
industry as worthy Rivals that some of
them do one or many things better than
you and you can learn from them but the
only true competitor is yourself how do
you do better than yourselves how do you
make your leaders better this year than
they were last year how do you make your
customer service better this year than
you were than they were last year how do
you make the your Innovation and your
and your and your online tools better
this year than they were last year and
learn from everybody else but compete
against yourself first and this is the
single best long-term strategy that you
can ever deploy and you will find
yourself way more Innovative because
you're not trying to me to or catch up
with whatever you know everybody else is
doing you're thinking for yourselves and
I'll give you one example to to drive
home the point which is Microsoft versus
Apple Steve Balmer at when he was the
CEO of Microsoft was hellbent on beating
apple and their iPod and he was going to
come up with his own product and he was
going to outperform and and beat Apple
literally he talked about it obsessively
right except Apple was ignoring
Microsoft and they were trying to
compete against themselves so at some
point it's true Microsoft's product
Microsoft's MP3 player the zoom actually
did get better than the iPod except
about a year or two later Apple
introduced the iPhone that rendered both
the iPod and the zoom at completely
obsolete Microsoft was competing against
apple apple was competing against itself
Apple was the Innovative company yeah
and that's that's the infinite game
exactly longterm fantastic well thank
you uh so much um it's been a true
pleasure getting the chance to chat to
you Simon um and you know uh parting
Parting Shot uh What's the title of your
next book where where is it going to be
all about power and and uh is that what
what it's going to focus on oh you've
been colluding with my publisher I see
um we'll see we'll see uh we'll see
where it goes but I can guarantee you
it'll be something Forward Thinking and
optimistic thank you so much Simon it
was a pleasure chatting to you thank you
so much uh for taking the time to chat
to us uh Team thank you for joining us
today it was great I hope you enjoyed uh
listening to Simon so many great lessons
for us as we think about our journey As
Leaders which is never truly done uh so
hopefully this uh Spurs you on to the
next leg thank you for joining have a
wonderful afternoon thank you everybody
thank you
Simon